On June 27 2014 the body of 20 year old
Andrew Sadek a promising electrical
student at the North Dakota State
College of Science in Wahpeton North
Dakota was pulled from the Red River
which borders North Dakota and Minnesota
Andrew had been missing for two months
and was found shot in the head wearing a
backpack full of rocks the grisly death
of a college student in one of the
safest towns in the state where violent
crime is extremely rare did not lead to
a sweeping investigation in fact police
immediately said they did not suspect
foul play
ruling out murder under these
circumstances is hard enough to believe
but what would be slowly revealed over
the following months is that Andrew had
been working as a confidential informant
for the police and that his school knew
that authorities were busting its
students and using them as bait to catch
drug dealers this is a story of
overzealous prosecution of minor drug
offenses by a task force answerable only
to itself callous indifference to a
grieving family and a lack of
transparency by authorities that raises
more questions than it answers paramount
among these questions why are police
using nonviolent first-time offenders in
the very dangerous role of confidential
informant
growing up on a family-owned farm in
Rogers North Dakota
Andrew was active with the raising of
the cattle and particularly close to his
parents who lost their older son Nick in
a car accident in 2005 we sent him off
to college he was excelling at college
and his dreams were to become an
electrician and take over the family
farm he was an all-american kids all I
can say he was every mother's dream
andrew was a few weeks shy of graduation
when he went missing in May 2014 days
later the statics received the shocking
news that a warrant had been issued for
Andrews arrest for two felony counts of
distributing a controlled substance when
he was in high school did he ever get in
trouble was he ever involved in any
criminal activity no he was not involved
in any criminal activity in high school
he only had one speeding ticket
throughout his entire life
so that's why this was such a shock to
us for two gut-wrenching months the
Sadek sprayed Andrew would come home to
the farm to help with the spring calving
while police continued to assume andrew
was on the lam because he still owed
them one last controlled by then Andrews
body was found shot wearing the backpack
filled with rocks not wearing the
clothes he was last seen in without his
wallet
an autopsy proved inconclusive and
determining suicide or homicide and no
weapon has yet been found but according
to the sadok's the police officer in
charge of the investigation tried to
convince them that their son put on the
rock filled backpack shot himself in the
head and somehow propelled himself into
the river from the very very beginning
when he went missing
the campus police have been treating it
as a suicide and how do they justify
that I would love some concrete evidence
as to why they justify that there's been
no note no one at the school described
him as being in a depressive state no
one described Andrew as being as a
depressive state no he was happy and
fun-loving and the police do not want to
pursue this as a potential murder
apparently according to sergeant Hill
Genson that's what kids do in that area
they commit suicide what the police knew
at the time but what the sadok's would
not learn for months was that Andrew had
been working
a confidential informant for the
southeast multi-county agency or semca a
Drug Task Force answerable only to its
own board a 12-person committee made up
of local senior police officers and
elected officials Andrew first came into
contact with simcha in April 2013 after
he twice sold marijuana a total of four
and a half grams or $80 worth to a
confidential informant shortly
thereafter a police raid on Andrews dorm
room turned up nothing but a small
plastic grinder and some marijuana
residue but the grinder plus the two
sales to the informant in a school zone
which in North Dakota includes colleges
was enough for authorities to threaten
Andrew with two Class A felony charges
each carrying a possible 20-year
sentence or he could voluntarily agree
to work as a confidential informant upon
enrolling at college Andrew signed a
waiver obligating the school to inform
his parents of any disciplinary issues
but the school never notified the
sadok's following the raid on Andrews
dorm room faced with the prospect of
forty years in prison and without
consulting a lawyer or his parents
Andrew chose to become an informant
agreeing to make two controlled buys
from each of three simcha targeted drug
dealers when Andrew was last seen
leaving his dorm building on May 1st
2014 he still owed simcha one last
controlled by refusing to accept
authorities speculation that Andrew had
committed suicide thus addicts hired a
private investigator who discovered a
significant amount of water in the wheel
wells under Andrews car suggesting that
someone may have driven Andrews car to
the banks of the river where his body
was found because andrew was found on
the Minnesota side of the river the
campus police claimed the case was not
in their jurisdiction which the North
Dakota Attorney General's Office
confirmed but according to Valley News
live a newscast in Fargo North Dakota
the Minnesota Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension told them that they have
nothing to do with the case for all the
agencies involved with busting Andrew
Sadek for selling a small amount of pot
no agency is willing to take the lead in
solving his violent death it took a long
time for us to get the results of the
autopsy so I called Steve helgesen the
person in charge of that case and I said
when will this be ready and he told me
it was not a top priority
nobody has ever answered a question who
directly has worked in this case any
reason you won't talk with us
answer my questions finding no help from
the local authorities the statics
demanded a statewide investigation which
culminated in a report from the North
Dakota Attorney General's Bureau of
Criminal Investigation released in
January 2015 the report revealed for the
first time that Andrew had been working
as a confidential informant for simcha
we had no idea Andrew was working as a
confidential informant until the Semco
review was done so when the warrant for
his arrest went out there was no
explanation about him working as a
confidential informant there was no
explanation of him working as a
confidential informant that the school
knew Andrew had been arrested on campus
in 2013 but allowed his parents to learn
this news only after he went missing
raises significant ethical and legal
questions in its own right but the fact
that semca only disclosed Andrew status
as a confidential informant because they
were forced to by the Attorney General
demonstrates a heartless lack of regard
for confidential informants even after
they end up dead the semca report runs
all of four and a half pages nearly half
of which merely names the board members
and the authors of the report and
despite the obvious dangers inherent
with being an informant working for the
police to bust drug dealers the report
found that semca had acted appropriately
when using Andrew a nonviolent
first-time offender as a CI the reports
conclusion offered for minor tweaks to
protocol such as holding a pre ops
briefing and assigning a supervisor to
each case when asked about Andrew
sadek's death Wahpeton Police Chief a
semca board member conceded that such
work exists in a dangerous subculture
but that he believes cops bend over
backwards to protect their CI these type
of investigations are conducted the same
way you know pretty much everywhere
where people breathe in and out law
enforcement it were generally not
popular you know like the sheep dog
isn't loved by the flock and they're
hated by the wolf but we do it anyway so
a 20 year old is dead no one knows what
happened to him and nothing's going to
change but how did we get here and what
comes next the lack of a statewide chain
of command allowed simcha to operate as
an entity answerable only to itself and
those sim cos board remains intact the
agency now falls under the jurisdiction
of the North Dakota Attorney
general when contacted by reason about
the use of college students as
confidential informants the Attorney
General's Office said we have no opinion
about confidential informants Andrew
Sadek is not the only young person to be
terrified into working as a CI in 2014 a
confidential informant at the University
of Massachusetts died of a drug overdose
prompting criticism that if his parents
had been notified he might have been
able to receive treatment for substance
abuse
earlier this year BuzzFeed reported on
the widespread use of confidential
informants on the campus of Ole Miss and
most notably in 2008 Florida State
student Rachel Hoffman was murdered when
police compelled her to make a gun
purchase her death led to statewide
reforms regarding the use of
confidential informants
when the police threatened to vigorously
prosecute young people unfamiliar with
the criminal justice system and then
used them as confidential informants
they assumed a certain amount of
responsibility for their safety but the
lack of interest by the agencies that
ensnared Andrew Sadek in investigating
his death as a potential murder suggest
they wish the case would just go away
which only begs the question why the
heartbroken static family searches for
justice for their son and hope that his
death can inspire reforms in North
Dakota and nationwide when he plans
moving forward in trying to push the
investigation along don't really have
any plans I just I don't know very
really even investigating I just don't
want other kids to be in this situation
you